and then the bruce willis story on that
let me tell you that this is cool oh my
god
you're asking about being starstruck so
here we are it's my big scene
it's the big scene of the movie really i
mean it turned out to be everyone
remembers the scene
and i'm in this pool
inside and as you know michael this
happens to you because you're such a
[ __ ] movie star no one you always
come laughs to set i know you like yeah
the star comes last everyone's got to be
there they're ready
so here i am and there
he is his name is bruce willis
hadn't met him he comes walking up he's
got a t-shirt on
he's just comes [ __ ] walking up he's
got a couple people i'll never forget it
tony comes over they start talking and
then they start coming into my area
where i'm going to be you know it's
because really my scene and there's
another actor playing the piano really
great comedic actor i can't remember his
name right now anyway it comes up to me
he doesn't look at me really
and tony goes hey bruce this is ken he
goes hey
that's all i said was hey i go hey bruce
really nice to meet you okay so let's do
the scene so we're doing the scene we're
just [ __ ] doing the scene and willis
isn't telling me anything i'm not i'm
just doing my thing my god i've
auditioned for this part like you did
with clint i i i'm ad-libbing a little
bit i'm having a cigarette and punch him
and all that and then it comes time for
him to kill me this took two days
and now we're into day two and he's
gonna break my nose and i'm gonna i'm
gonna die and willis goes
okay so when i and he never called me
kim or my name just him i was just him
so when i hit him you know when i punch
him he's going to fall into the pool
and that'll be that
and michael i went
i
i don't want to [ __ ] fall under the
pool takeout in my head i don't want to
so called tony over i said tony nothing
for nothing
i don't see it that way he goes what do
you mean he goes i don't i don't see me
flying into the pool
he goes well how do you see it i go well
can we just do one
he goes sure so he goes hey bruce bruce
we're gonna do one for kim we're gonna
do one for camilla sure all right all
right
he [ __ ] goes and he break and i fell
right on my ass michael like a 10 year
old boy and then i flopped back
and the camera's still rolling willa
showed me this later and everyone is
laughing their [ __ ] heads off
they're clapping they're laughing and
tony comes over and goes i think we got
it i think we got it in one well let's
go that was pretty [ __ ] good and we
did
we did a couple close-ups and [ __ ] but
no that was it one take a couple cameras
i fell on my ass like a little boy and
then i flopped back they couldn't
believe that i could fall on my butt
like that and stay straight like a tree
and then
anyway
that was my bruise wow so you impressed
bruce
i think so
because we've become buddies we've done
a couple since then
and i always like hanging with him he
loves my wife
i haven't seen him in 10 years probably
but
he uh
he's a good guy he's a really good guy
and he's battling something now that no
one wants to go through
wow
you